huit mille enfants autistes naissent
chaque année en france
ici au centre hospitalier charcot de
saint-cyr-l'ecole la prise en charge de
ces enfants va être améliorée lundi 12
décembre le centre a inauguré son
nouveau pôle de psychiatrie infanto
juvénile qui était important c'est le
scandale ce que les québécois appellent
le virage ambulatoire c'est-à-dire au
lieu de subtiliser les maires ou les
enfants 24 24 on les prend en charge
soit hospitalisé à l'hôpital de jour
soit en visite à domicile soit par des
consultations
donc c'est une prise en charge plus
légère ça permet aussi de prendre en
charge plus de personnes parmi les trois
nouvelles unités l'hôpital de jour
united' et le jardin d'enfants
thérapeutique
toutes deux sont consacrés aux enfants
souffrant de troubles du développement
une quarantaine seront accueillis la
troisième l'unité parents bébé est dédié
aux difficultés qui suivent
l'accouchement
ça peut être un conflit de couple ça
peut être une mère célibataire ça peut
être une maman qui est porteuse d'une
maladie un enfant qui lui-même est
porteur d'une maladie
donc ça va 2 j'ai envie de dire de la
simple guidances parentale à de vrais
consultations psychologiques
pédopsychiatrique voir voir un
accompagnement médical sur des
pathologies particulières
la dépression post partum toucherait 10
à 20% des femmes elles pourront donc
trouver un soutien si kia trick à la
place de l'ancienne maternologie de
l'établissement au total l'hôpital a
investi 230 mille euros pour les trois
unités